we're going to start today with dyed
suddenly what does that mean someone
died suddenly has become the new code
for the covid vaccine is killing people
now this has all come to an extremely
stupid Crescendo because of what
happened with the collapse and cardiac
arrest of NFL football player Damar
Hamlin on the field uh during an NFL
game a little over a week ago and as you
know if you've been watching this
program because we've been we've been
following it I even got some voicemails
about it that I played for you the gist
of the story is that Demar Hamlin
collapsed not because he got hit in a
particular way
but because of the covet vaccine the
covet vaccine which by the way nobody
knew whether Demar Hamlin had actually
received at the time that people started
saying the vaccine is to blame and this
brings us to a bigger story that has
been building the died suddenly
conspiracy theory is the idea that
people who have received the covid-19
vaccine are either dying at an unusual
rate the story is always otherwise
healthy people are suddenly dying for
unexplained reasons that's one piece of
it or experiencing health effects of
different different kinds now there is a
lot that we could say about this and so
many different things there's even a
film called died suddenly which rehashes
a lot of these same debunked claims but
a lot of this has to do with some really
basic logical fallacies that I hope I've
done an okay job of educating people
about over the years on the show and it
also has to do with something called the
base rate bias so there's really two
things going on here first of all it's a
fundamental issue of correlation versus
causation we sometimes call this
post-hoc Ergo Proctor Hawk meaning
it happened afterwards therefore it
happened because of
or to put it another way
B happened after a therefore a must have
caused B
and uh when you zoom out you very
quickly see how faulty this sort of
thinking is so let's start tight and
then we'll zoom out let's start with
Demar Hamlin are there examples of
cardiac arrest during sporting events
among athletes yeah there are
um you know in in major sports Detroit
Lion Chuck Hughes had a fatal heart
attack on the field in 1971. that's the
only NFL player to die while playing
um Danish soccer player Christian
Erickson suffered Cardiac Arrest during
a tournament in 2021 Hockey Hall of
Famer Chris pronger's heart stopped when
he was hit in the chest by a hockey puck
NHL player J boomister or bowmeester I'm
not exactly sure on the pronunciation
collapsed on the bench after a cardiac
episode Mark Vivienne foe died during a
2003 semi-final match from an
undiagnosed heart condition that was a
soccer death all of these
um uh have not have not been claimed to
have anything to do with vaccines most
of them predate the covet vaccines so
the Demar Hamlin situation is not unique
but that's not really the big story
the big story is you have to understand
base rates when you test a vaccine as
was done by Pfizer and moderna before
the covet vaccines were fully released
to the public
um a lot of these uh studies clinical
trials had 40 000 adults for example 40
000 adults and so someone who wants to
think critically about this issue rather
than fear Monger or spread conspiracy
theories would say if you have a group
of adults if you take 18 plus 40 000
people distributed among ages how many
of them would you expect to die over a
three-month period aside from whether
you're testing anything and what I mean
by that is if you take a group of forty
thousand people
and you just follow them for three
months
you would expect some to die if their
ages are normally distributed and it's a
tough question to answer exactly for a
vaccine test group because it could
depend on particular choices that are
made for who's included or who's not
who's not included but there's something
called the crude death rate that's the
number of deaths per thousand people a
year overall for in the U.S the crude
death rate is 7.8 meaning over the
course of a year
you would expect 7.8 deaths per 100
people of per thousand people for all
different causes now if we use that rate
we would estimate that over a
three-month period you would expect
between five and six deaths per hundred
people these are rough numbers so if
you've got a group of 40 000 people you
would expect to see about 235 of them
die over a three-month period this is
aside from testing anything but that's
just an estimate and the other thing
that's important to consider is that
that number that I gave you 7.8
that's not just adults that's everybody
that includes younger people the death
rate for 18 plus again aside from
testing a vaccine would be higher than
the death rate for the entire population
because the risk of death increases with
age and when you do only 18 plus you
would have a higher expected death rate
than for people of all ages all the way
down to newborn so it's an estimate the
number of people you would expect to die
in a group of forty thousand would vary
but the point of it is the fact that
people died in the three months after
getting a vaccine doesn't actually tell
us anything people die and a group of
forty thousand people will die so then
we get to this particular died suddenly
conspiracy theory here they want to talk
about young people are dying healthy
young people are dying now first of all
when we say healthy in many cases we
don't actually know the full history and
what we mean by healthy can vary in a
lot of different ways so that is
fallacious and lacks evidence at the top
of the of the discussion but here's the
real really important thing the crude
death rate for those aged 18 to 34 is
about 3.3 deaths per thousand people per
year that's just the average crude death
rate in the United States the CDC
believes about 65 percent of those aged
18 to 24 got a full regimen of the covet
vaccine that means the two initial doses
forget about boosters that's not part of
the data but 65 percent of those 18 to
24 got the two doses that means if we
have about 32 million people aged 18 to
24. 65 percent of them are vaccinated
meaning 21 million people aged 18 to 24
received the full dose of vaccines if
you look at that crude death rate
and you look at the number of people who
have gotten vaccinated you would expect
70
000 deaths among that group over the
course of a year now you will have
endless circumstances you will have
motor vehicle accidents you will have uh
cardiac episodes you will have cancer
you will have all you will have covid-19
in some of you will have all those
different things the fact that some
people aged 18 to 24 died
in the period after which they got a
vaccine tells you nothing five stories
ten stories 20 stories about a 21 year
old who died seven months after getting
a vaccine
and we don't exactly know the
circumstances or we vaguely know but
it's a privacy issue it doesn't tell us
anything about the safety of vaccines
and what is missing from this analysis
in most cases is this issue of the base
rates what are the base rates of death
in all of these different categories
it's basic stats it's basic research
methods and its basic common sense and
logic and that is not a surprise then
that it is completely missing from the
minds and the discussions of these
conspiracy theorists so don't fall for
it don't fall for it understand these
Concepts causation correlation base
rates critical stuff